I was in shock because it felt like he
was exposing me when Stefani gets raw
and emotional as she opens up about her
love life
past and present on the Howard Stern
Show during her interview with Howard
Stern on Wednesday Gwen Stefani revealed
details of how her romance with fellow
voice coach Blake Shelton developed we
just started this friendship which was
just unbelievable that God would put us
in a position to have each other at that
moment in that like in the same exact
moment when taping for the voice began
Blake announced he was splitting from
ex-wife Miranda Lambert but no one
except for Gwen's parents knew about her
split from Gavin Rossdale she ended up
confiding in Blake he came on my show
ever the first time he's ever walked to
my chair and he was like I'm sick from
what I think he was just like and I
never saw him like look so upset you're
I'm saying and then so then I was like I
gotta talk to you and while Gwen says
there was no plan to start a
relationship the two started emailing
here and there and over time it
progressed I wasn't trying to start a
relationship I was just trying right now
died 46 year old singer candidly admits
that she was in hell after her split
from Gavin who allegedly cheated on her
with her nanny I just felt like such a
loser you know and I just got myself up
I remember driving down it's making me
cry now but driving down like Santa
Monica Boulevard just crying my eyes out
going what am i doing right now if you
also admits to stern that although it is
painful every time she sings used to
love you the album came pouring out of
her because of the divorce and falling
in love with Blake